we actually have two speakers
coming up at the same time they both
both work for the new york city council
data team
rose has a twin sister who also works
for the new york city government
and brooke knows all the words to the
rap in the movie
teen witch definitely got to get some
twin jokes in here or something
so everyone please welcome to the stage
rose and brooke thank you jared for the
introductions
the new york city council is the city's
law making legislative body
we will go over some examples of
projects that show the role of data in
the new york city's law making process
so our work leads to smarter laws
and therefore that leads to improving
the lives of new yorkers
here is our team our lovely team
pictures of us
we are a team that has background in
physics statistics
visualization communication policy and
planning
the team is mostly in our user group
next slide so our mission is to promote
a
data-driven approach to the new york
city council's decision-making
processes um this is accomplished by
working
closely with the legislative staff
while they're generating laws and um
doing oversight duties and communicating
our findings to
the general public
so what what we do so we have three main
data functions um the first one is
data laws data laws are
laws that require agencies to report
data to us and this feeds
the second pillar which is data analysis
and data analysis is a step
where we make sense of the data and that
will inform
existing and future legislation and
lastly
we wrap up the results nicely and
visualizations and communicate
findings to internal staff
and to the public so now we will give
some examples of our work
in each of these three functions and
brooke um if you can please tell us what
we do
in terms of data analysis sure so um
as far as data analysis goes it's one of
our core functions
we source data we often source data from
the open
the new york city open data portal which
is an amazing resource if you don't know
about it
we clean data we transform it we model
it and then we eventually turn our
findings into
actionable insights that will inform
legislation and policy
um go to the next slide so as rose
mentioned before
um there's like some nice synergy
between all of these steps
and especially between the reporting
bill or the data law bill and then the
like sort of
um the like data laws and then the
analysis
side of things so a good example of this
sort of synergy
is this climate mobilization act or
local on 97
local on 97 mandated or
set sort of thresholds on
um how many how much greenhouse gases
buildings over 25 000 square feet or
more um can emit
um and so in order to come up with these
thresholds we needed to
understand the sort of universe of
emissivity to understand
what like what characteristics um
a building had that sort of were
predictive of
emitting greenhouse gases so um
this law relied heavily on a reporting
bill law
local law 84 which mandated
that buildings of that size report on
energy usage
so we um in order to like
understand and set reasonable and
achievable
threshold for these buildings we had to
really like investigate
what features of a building were
predictive of
emissivity so um we used a lot of
different
kinds of models to interrogate that
information um we use
hd boost we use forecast
um to understand the seasonality and
what we came up with was that
um and it's not surprising but that it's
not so much like the way a builder
building is constructed or sort of like
where
the building sits on a hill but it's
really all about the work that is being
done within the building that's going to
be most predictive of how many
how much greenhouse gas it emits um so
then we were able to use this
information to group
buildings like buildings within like
buildings and
sort of like create these buckets and
then sort of reasonable thresholds
within these
buckets that um we felt were fair
because
um we set like sort of limits
the thresholds were like relative to
other like buildings
so um that was a really
exciting and big law that we worked on
and it will hopefully have a major
impact
on the city as the mayor and
his administration have have set this
goal of
an eighty percent reduction of
greenhouse gas emissions by 2050.
go to the next slide
um the next one yes
so a good example also of our work
um informing policy is
what we sort of did with the taxi
medallion task force
so this task force convened
to try and understand and fix
this sort of crisis that
yellow cab drivers are facing so just to
summarize
if you're a yellow cab driver in new
york city you need to own a medallion
medallions have been increasing in cost
over the last
10 years um about and
the amount that you can sort of make
being a taxi
a yellow cab driver has gone down um so
we wanted to
understand when and why this is
happening
so we looked at um historical data
daily sort of
[Music]
daily earnings data for each medallion
and try to understand like i mean
there's seasonality of course but try to
understand like at what point did the
trend start to really sharply decline
um and we found that that and it's not
surprising but
it's nice to have this confirmed with
data that as soon as um
as soon as like around the time that
these four higher gig economy
sort of lift and uber um cars came onto
the scene and saturated the market
that's when
sort of um wages started to really
really decline
and so um we
incorporated that into our the policy
recommendations that went to the state
finally
and i think recently the state released
some
um recommendations on how to sort of fix
and help
mitigate this this issue
[Music]
so as we mentioned before data laws or
reporting bills
are really important to the work we do
because they give us the data that we
need in order to
do the important analyses and sort of
reframe
um legislative issues in like a more
scientific way
so reporting bills require city agencies
to report specific info on their
activities to the city council and or
the open data portal so
metrics that show their sort of what
sort of work they're doing and how
well they're doing that work um
next slide so i'll go through the next
the next couple slides will be like
contacts like what is the process and um
and how does a bill become a law and
where do we sort of step in
so the process for creating a data law
and
more broadly legislation is that we
sit down with central staff or
elected officials and their staff
members
to understand the issue at hand and see
if it can be reframed in a quantitative
way
um so we sit down with them we're like
is there
you know is there too much trash in a
neighborhood
and should we have more
better service in that neighborhood or
is that just one block
and maybe some anomaly that doesn't
require like a whole entire
sort of law to fix um oftentimes
we realize that we don't have enough
data that there is some data that like
can describe the problem like
a little bit but maybe not enough to
really like understand why the problem
is and so oftentimes the solution is we
have to get
more data and that requires the
reporting bill
we come up with this issue of privacy
concerns
as data people we want high resolution
very granular spatio temporal data
and um we have to also be mindful
of people's privacy especially you know
in the city of new york there's lots of
um
lots of you know concerns there um
we also like an interesting sort of
thing that we have to consider is that
the laws have to be future proof so we
can't
um we can't like specify or we it's
it's important to like make sure that
the laws are flexible
in the future so if we specify specific
technology that may eventually become
obsolete
um that law is going to be kind of like
encumbered by that specification
it's going to be hard to adjust and so
we want to make sure that everything
sort of like we describe the technology
but we don't um
use specific sort of brands
um which has been a tricky thing for
for us go to the next slide
um so the process of a bill becoming a
law
so a bill starts out as a and i'm sure
everyone is
maybe a lot of people are familiar with
this process but it might be a little
bit
different at the city level but um
an idea becomes a sort of legislative
request
a legislative request is the
formalization of like the idea so it
becomes
something that then um gets
circulated within staff members lawyers
and and is turned from an idea into
legalese so it's turned into legal
language
this is where we often sit down with the
lawyers and talk about how
um to make sure that like all of the
quantitative
aspects of this idea or of this issue
are considered and if it is a reporting
bill
are we asking for the like right you
know level of granularity are we asking
for um right like the right sort of
temporal
sequence are we asking for the right
geographic sort of unit
are we asking for enough information
that would let us sort of like answer
the question or solve the problem or
you know monitor the issue um
so this is a this is where we spend a
lot of time at this step
um the bill then once we have these like
sort of internal
conversations the bill is introduced
and that's when after that point that's
when the public has a chance and
advocates have a chance to sort of weigh
in and say you know remind us of things
that we didn't think of
which happens every time um it's a huge
important step
um and then you know eventually once all
of that sort of like
lots of editing and drafting and
sort of reformatting the bill it
becomes this thing that then is um gets
voted on
and that's um that needs
a majority vote from the council and
then the mayor
then goes to the mayor's desk and the
mayor can either redo it which i don't
think he has
done in his in this administration
um or he can sign it um or he can just
leave it be and then it becomes the law
after 30 days so rosa's going to give
you an example of one of our reporting
bills
that's very timely and we're really
excited about because we're working on
it actively
um so the pay equity bill is an example
where we provided a lot of support
to the legislative strat legislative um
staff that were drafting the bill
um we helped them think through um the
language
so the characteristics and variables
that should be included
in the bill um so the intent of the pay
equity reporting bill
is for agencies to report employee
information
to us that way we can then investigate
paying equities
in the city workforce so during this
process of drafting and negotiating the
bill
we met with advocates and the agencies
involved
in this process which is the department
of administrative services
this is the new york city agency that
collects employee information for
a lot of city of the city workforce
so the woman in the photo is council
member
laurie cumbo she is the prime sponsor of
the bill she is very excited and happy
about this bill as you can see
so when talking with her and with
advocates they were
um they only had in mind three variables
um gender race and age they
were very fixed that these variables
were enough to explain
um pain equities and it might be the
case but we told them that
these three variables are not enough
there might be other
confounding variables or characteristics
that will do a better job
in explaining pay differences so we
listed
a whole bunch of them as you can see up
here so some of them are
like years of experience are you in a
manager position
um your education level et cetera
so um this helped significantly in order
for us
to answer the question that they were
looking for to explain pay inequities
um so it so this bill
is one of the first of its kind as well
in terms of how the data is being
reported to us
we will be getting access to the data
via an
api um we are very excited
so the city council will have access to
um person-level data um
so there's privacy concerns here um
so we only have access to this data set
for a
period of time every year
and the public so advocates really
wanted
this data to be available for the public
to view
and analyze but due to privacy issues
it was agreed upon to make public an
aggregated version
and not all the variables um
so this is already out there if anyone's
interested
i guess if we share slides or you can
search on the open data portal
for the local law it's out there but um
we're very we just so this is the
timeline um before covid of when we
would
receive access um to the api
so we just got access to it a week ago
and we're in the middle
of just digging into the data we have no
immediate findings yet we're we we know
that we have to deal with missing data
we
don't know how consistent employee
information is reported across all the
agencies
but that's something that we're very
excited to
dig into and maybe at a future point or
i'm sure there will probably be a
release of the findings and
we'll um we'll be in the news
um okay so moving on to our last
data function um it's data visualization
so communicating our findings in a way
that is easily understandable by
everyone and pushing
our work onto github or the council web
page
for others to add and collaborate on is
uh
the main goal of this um process
so an example of a project
um that does this is
evictions in new york city um so this
project we worked on it
when the speaker of the council was
held another position at the same time
the interim public advocate
the former public advocate went on to
another role
so i guess due to law he becomes the
interim public advocate
so evictions is a big issue area for the
council
the council passed also another
legislation first of its kind called
uh right to council so this legislation
seeks to
decrease or address the eviction crisis
in new york city by
providing um free legal assistance
to those going through an evictions
proceeding um it's being rolled out
in stages so at one point um
i have 20 something i'm not too sure
it'll be available across the whole city
um but also this remains an ongoing
issue
um due to covid there was there's a
moratorium on evictions but
at the end of the year it will be lifted
unless it's extended
so there might be a big rise in
evictions um
if it's not extended um so we
put this page together to showcase um
the council's bill and to sort of to see
um the facts of this bill
there has been decreases in evictions in
the city
and also just to show where it still
remains uh
an issue as you can see in the bronx
there's a lot of
evictions there um so in this process
of putting the charts and the maps
together
the data source the victim data set on
the open data portal
lacked latitude and longitude columns
despite having address information so
the addresses
were very dirty so if you were to put
them
in a geocoder it wouldn't um spit out
the latitude and longitude for you it
would give you an n
a so what we did was did a script that
cleaned the addresses
um so using g sub and regular
expressions to clean the addresses
we were able to get the latitude and
longitudes
using the new york city's geocoding api
and that led us to be able to map at
this fine level
before that the only maps of evictions
in the city were at the zip code level
so advocates were really excited to see
these maps out there and um they
the housing data advocates reached out
to us thanking for
our work and putting the code out there
it helped them um
cross check their own work that they've
been doing on evictions and
hopefully expand on our scope of the
project at that time
so this sort of hits all our points and
goals of
data visualization this project
[Music]
so i guess to start wrapping up um
maybe brooke do you want to tell us what
our
has been our success strategies and um
embedding data at the council sure um
so i guess the main reason the reason
why we exist is because we have support
from
leadership and higher ups and that our
speaker of the city council
does really believe in data and using
data to inform policy and legislation
and
all of our bosses really do believe in
that too
and it's um and lawyers who are writing
the laws are really receptive to like
conversations with us about
how to use data and how to
think about data in like new and
different ways when it comes to
legislation
um but i think like and these like sort
of strengths predate me because i'm
newer than rose and much of the team but
um
that we have a strong like sort of core
like visualization effort and this um
this sort of like goal or this um
ethos of like
making our findings really interpretable
and legible to the general public we
strongly believe that everyone should be
able to understand our results
and that's um really big especially when
you're dealing with so many different
audiences like non-technical and
technical
um like everyone should be able to
understand things and
visualization i think is really
important for that
um and then we have some really strong
um
quantitative and technical people on our
team that can
like in creative ways reframe these
you know legislative issues or these
constituent issues almost
into quantitative scientific um
questions and so we're i think we're
really good at like
incorporating the scientific method and
just using our
scientific backgrounds and making that
really like
integral into the legislative process
um and that's yeah those are things i'm
really excited about
rose do you want to talk about the
things that are hard
there are challenges and that we're
slowly chipping at
and still maybe walls to
climb over um so sometimes
due to timelines or the staff are just
too busy
or maybe even they forget us they bring
us in too late
so there's a question a problem that
they want us
to help with and they're like can you do
this by tomorrow
and we're like uh well probably not
so we don't have the opportunity at that
time to go
in depth or like in depth enough to give
them
an adequate correct response to their
question and that also feeds into
managing expectations
sometimes they think we can do magic but
sometimes we're limited to the quality
of the data the data quality is poor
we can't give um sort of estimates with
a certain amount of certainty
um things like that and then lastly our
own projects
uh most of the time our work is very
reactive to what's
in the news or agendas
of the the council and other council
members
so long-term projects that we have
our time on them is limited
compared to the amount of time we spend
on um
these more reactive short-term projects
um so i guess to summarize um
our role at the council is new
and um i guess for the better for
new yorkers and the laws that are coming
out of it before
there was no scientific or
quantitative thinking put into a lot of
these laws
so sometimes like um
so like more thought is going to towards
um
like numbers that are being um written
into the law
so or um processes have
gone through like some sort of check of
what's happening
what's the data telling us and maybe
that sometimes this
can contradict what a constituent thinks
is happening on their block and they
assume that that's happening everywhere
in new york city
um so i think we've in a short amount of
time we've
done a lot but we still have some
challenges um
i don't know brooke if you want to add
anything i mean we're a team that has
grown from i think it was just
rose and one other maybe two other
people
and um like the confidence of the growth
like the confidence in what we do is
like um
sort of represented by how much our team
has grown
and how um yeah like
the like work that we've sort of done
at a micro and macro scale whether it be
like here's the data set that you need
and here's that like
mean that you are looking for to like
more sophisticated models to understand
like really complex problems so i just
think yeah
we have a and we work on a lot of
different projects
a lot of different topics so you're not
working on one
thing forever you're working on housing
and then you're working on
greenhouse gases and then you're working
on you know
i don't know a million other things
so it's so thanks to everyone that's
watching
um here is our contact info for our team
um our github page um
our website and our twitter handles so
if you guys have any questions feel free
to reach out to us
and thank you again for watching
we still have more ahead for you
and i'll show you that in a second but i
do think that when they talk about how
to make a bill
did anybody else think that they should
make a city version of schoolhouse rock
i think that would be great to see a
thing involving schoolhouse rock
i think that would be pretty awesome